The sample may not look very much,
but it's sample of the saltiest water that you can find on this
planet. It comes from a really small lake, not even a lake,
a pond in the north of Ethiopia.
This was collected by one of my friends at bothered Paris when he was on
holiday collected in a plastic water bottle.
And then he analyzed it and found that it was the saltiest
water that's ever been discovered.
And he's got it into the Guinness world records Ethiopia in case you've
forgotten is on the Eastern part of Africa,
quite close to the equator and bright in the north.
There's a region called the Danica depression, which is well below sea level.
It's part of the rift valley,
which is an area of huge seismic and volcanic
activity. And in 2005,
following an earthquake, a new lake appeared
I'm. So I don't pronounce it correctly,
but its name looks to me as if it's pronounced gait. Allah,
what is really unusual is the water is very hot.
60 degrees centigrade.
That's hotter than you can bear to jump into.
And it's hot because there is a hot spring coming through the
volcanic rock.
And not only is it coming up and bubbling up into the lake,
you can see bubbles coming up, but at the same time,
it is desolving souls that are in the soil.
The concentration of the salt is so high mixture of
calcium and magnesium chloride that the water is actually saturated.
You cannot physically dissolve any more salt.
There is 43.3% dissolve solid by
weight. What that means is if you have a liter of water,
you have 433 grams of dissolved, solid,
nearly half the weight of the water.
Even on this bowl sample that I've got,
you can see a big difference in weight. I've got an empty bottle,
a bottle of water and a bottle of water from the pond.
We weigh the empty bottle. And this balance has a thing that is called tear,
which allows us to set it to zero when the bottles on there.
So we'll just way whatever's in the bottle we put on
the water comes to 15.5.
We put this on here. 22.2.
The other thing that you might notice is that because this water is at
room temperature and this room in Nottingham is barely 20 degrees
today that some of the salt has,
you can see that the crystals at the bottom,
and this is because in general,
these types of souls dissolve better in hot water than they do in
cold water. So when you put the water in here, let it cool down.
Some of the things precipitate,
some of you who know chemistry will say calcium chloride and magnesium
chloride the colorless. So why is this water yellow?
And the answer is that it contains a trace of iron three,
which forms quite a strong yellow color in the presence of high concentrations
of chloride. So although it looks yellow,
the yellow component is a really tiny part. Of course,
people have been looking for the saltiest water in the world for some time,
this is a new record, and you might wonder what was the previous record?
And the previous record was a pond called the Don one
pond in the Antarctica where there was a very,
or there still is a very salty lake,
which has 403 grams per liter of dissolve sold.
Now, the reason why it's not as salty as this pound in
Ethiopia is because Ethiopia is near the equator and the water
is hotter than the nine ticker as you cool down
water, even though it's still saturated, it contains less salt.
And the colder you go, the less and less salt will dissolve.
Eventually when it freezes to ice, you get no salt in it at all.
You might ask, how does this compare with the dead sea?
I think it's about twice as much so or dissolve material as the dead sea.
According to Brady the dead sea water tastes like acid.
Oh yeah, it's salty
this, but broadly it will.
It will taste twice as awful unless its taste is
logarithmic.
In which case it might be a lot more compared to seawater is about
14 times as salty. Well,
14 times as much dissolved sold seawater also has a
different composition. It has a lot of sodium chloride in it,
whereas there's very little sodium in this.
And the reason is that this is not a pond where sea
water has evaporated,
but it's come from dissolved souls and the ground,
which do not originate from the seed.
This is Eduardo's paper published in the journal called
aquatic geochemistry. Have you ever published in that one? No,
because I'm not a geo chemist and I study water is that water
at Walter is not,
but he is a good chemist and good canvas can do anything.
The chemical analysis of the water of the gate, Talla pond,
a small water body located in the Danica depression.
Ethiopia resulted to be the most, say line water,
body on earth with total dissolved solids of
433 grams per kilogram.
Yeah.
And when they started making these aerosols in the
aerosols, they put a molecule rather like this,
which has carbon in the middle.
[inaudible].
This is their Carnegie river.
It's about 20 kilometers from the city center.
And I'm where right in the middle of a.